Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In most video games that we've seen running
for at least a few moments, we learn to anticipate
what is going to happen in the next second,
and even more, if given the patience and skills,
we could attempt to recreate parts of the
game itself.
And what you see here in this work is actually
even better, because it requires neither the
patience nor the skills to do that.
So here is the million dollar idea: let's
have a learning algorithm look at some video
game footage, and then, ask it to recreate
that so we can indulge in playing it.
The concept is demonstrated on the Super Mario
game and later, you will also see some results
with the millenial childhood favorite, Mega
Man.
There are many previous works that hook into
the source code of these games and try to
read and predict what happens next by reading
the code-level instructions.
But not in this case, because this technique
looks at the video output and the learning
takes place on the level of pixels, therefore,
no access to the inner workings of the game
is necessary.
The algorithm is given two things for the
learning process: one, a sprite pallette that
contains all the possible elements that can
appear in the game, including landscape tiles,
enemies, coins and so on.
And two, we also provide an input video sequence
with one playthrough of the game to demonstrate
the mechanics and possible interactions between
these game elements.
A video is a series of frames, from which
the technique learns how a frame can be advanced
to the next one.
After it has been exposed to enough training
samples, it will be able to do this prediction
by itself on unknown frames that it hasn't
seen before.
This pretty much means that we can start playing
the game that it tries to mimic.
And there are similarities across many games
that could be exploited, endowing the learning
algorithms with knowledge reused from other
games, making them able to recreate even higher
quality computer games, even in cases where
a given scenario hasn't played out in the
training footage.
It used to be the privilege of computer graphics
researchers to play video games during work
hours, but apparently, scientists in machine
learning also caught up in this regard.
Way to go!
A word about limitations.
As the predictions are not very speedy and
are based off of a set of facts learned from
the video sequences, it is a question as to
how well this technique would generalize to
more complex 3d video games.
As almost all research works, this is a stepping
stone, but a very important one at that as
this is a proof of concept for a really cool
idea.
You know the drill, a couple papers down the
line and we'll see the idea significantly
improved.
The results are clearly not perfect, but it
is a nice demonstration of a new concept,
and knowing the rate of progress in machine
learning research, you will very soon see
some absolutely unreal results.
What's even more, I expect that new levels,
enemy types and mechanics will soon be synthesized
to already existing games via generative adversarial
networks, or generative latent optimization.
If you would like to hear more about these,
as always, the links are available in the
video description.
Also, if you enjoyed this episode, please
make sure to help us tell these incredible
stories to more and more people by supporting
us on Patreon.
Your support has always been absolutely amazing.
Details are available in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!